let's now move to the fourth talk
of this track and it's my pleasure to
introduce you to dr dana mustafa
from the department of pathology humor
immunopathology laboratory
of the erasmus university medical center
in rotterdam
the topic of our talk is the new
microenvironment
of pancreatic cancer
hello good afternoon from the
netherlands
i'm adil mustafa and i'm an assistant
professor and the leader of the geomics
facility
at the tumor immune pathology in erasmus
medical center
um today i will talk about
as the title indicates i will talk about
immune infiltration
and how that how the microenvironment of
pancreatic cancer
may influence the survival of the
patients
but before i start i'd like to first
give my thanks to nanoshrink company
for arranging this virtual oncology
meeting
and for giving me the opportunity to
talk about our work
in the lab i'd also like to thank
the chair lady who introduced me a bit
earlier
so let me start by refreshing your
memories about the bankiness
parenchy is part of our digestive system
it is in the abdomen just behind the
stomach
and it's two in one organ so it
functions
as a as a gland and it has
two functions basically endocrine
function
that regulates blood sugar and excrement
function
mainly by producing enzymes to digest
food
the type of pancreatic cancer depends on
the cell's
origin if cancer starts from isolated
cells its partner cells that they are
responsible to produce
insulin endocrine cells then
the type of cancer is going to be
neuroendocrine
or pancreatic neuro endocrine tumor
and it presents almost 10 percent of
pancreatic cancer
we lost some famous people for this type
of cancer
we lost franklin and we lost steve jobs
for this type of cancer
if that kinetic cancer originated from
us in our cells
we refer to it as pancreatic ductal
adrenal carcinoma
and this is a complete different type of
tumor we
lost unfortunately some famous people
pavarotti
and recently this year we lost we lost
elf and han
for this time of tuesday and kinetic
cancer especially when kinetic doctor
latino carcinoma
i refer to it in my talk as pancreatic
cancer but what i mean is pancreatic
oxalatinocarcinoma
which is the most common type of
pancreatic cancer
and it represents more than 90 percent
of pancreatic cancer
unfortunately it's a very bad disease
it's expected to be the leading cause of
cancer-related death
in 2013. it's
painful disease because the tumor cells
invade nerves
they also invade lymphatics and veins
and they metastasize
the five-year survivor rate is five
percent
and most patients die within two years
the reason for that because it's an
asymptomatic disease
until the patient develops some symptoms
and they come to the clinic to be
checked
the cancer is already there and it's
in a lot of cases it's already spread
histological level
the cancer pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma they are the granular or
doctor differentiation
so it's the epithelial neoplasm of
granular
differentiation it's a highly
heterogeneous disease
it's characterized by remarkable dismal
place
or fibroblasts in some cases
dyspoplasia can represent 50 percent of
the tumor or even
more than have a very poor angiogenesis
or a blood supply
the dysmorblasia is a very important
important
component of pancreatic cancer
and it's mainly composed of
extracellular and matrix proteins
fibroblasts a lot of fibroblasts various
types of fibrocasts
pancreatic stillated cells and immune
cells
immune cells or tumor infiltrated
lymphocytes recently since
five seven years ago they started to
have a
huge highlight because of the importance
of these
immune cells as a part of the tumor
it's usually the balance between the
tumor suppressor and the tumor
progression
that it is a balance in the immune cells
that drive the tumor either towards
suppression
or progression so we usually refer to
them as
good and bad players not per se it's the
balance between the
good and bad players is the most
important thing
they can predict the response to therapy
over all survival
regression free survival it's very
important to know not
only the amount of infiltration cells
not only the type of infiltration cells
but also their location
and their ratio relative to each other
understanding the immune system
may open therapeutic options like we see
with immune checkpoint inhibitors
now previously our group has published
and studied the immune component of
pancreatic cancer
we have uh i'm referring to one of the
publications
and in this publication we did by
immunohistochemistry we stained for
several types of t
cells the eighth d40 regulatory cells
marked by fox p3 also some immune
checkpoint inhibitors
and what we concluded in that article
pancreatic cancer or pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma
specific is low in cd8
t cell infiltration and high in immune
suppressive myelin cells
we also show an evidence that the
cd8 to fox p3 ratio
the high city a to fox b3 ratio is
associated with favorable
outcome like kabul meyer
shows here
if we look at the literature and
research foreign kinetic cancer
together with micro in your micro
environment or micro environment
we see number of publications increase
in the last
five to seven years and that is in
relation with the energy point
inhibitors and technical therapy that's
been introduced to
treat cancer patients in general so
there is a demand and there is a huge
need to understand
the micro environment and specifically
the immune micro environment
not only invent kinetic cancer but also
in other types of diseases
and that is one of our focus on our
understanding the immune
micro environment of
now several publications i'm referring
to view here
they um hypothesized and suggest the
relation
between tumor-associated macrophages and
fibroblasts
which is the desmoglasia this is where
mainly we
we see a lot of infiltration of immune
cells some
inhibit and some suppress the tumor
cells
there is recently a review and the
meta-analysis
trying to understand the prognostic
value of genetic infiltration
and trying to understand other
publications
are highlighting the importance of
understanding the landscape of immune
cell infiltration
to predict the clinical outcome and to
have an implication
in regulated personality i'm listing
here few
examples the recent publications however
what i like to highlight is
most of these publications are focusing
on results
so the highlights of these publications
is about
the infiltration of diesels in the
kinetic cancer
they protect better survival especially
cd8
associated with a better outcome
deregulatory cells or fox e3 t cells
are associated with poor outcome but as
you see
most of these publications are about
t-cells
and they recommend that other types of
cells like for example cd-20
which are b cells or natural rectangles
should be studied
original of what i'm presenting today is
unfortunately most of pancreatic cancer
patients they died in the first couple
of years as i told you earlier
however there is a very small subgroup
of patients
since they survive for many more years
so there are factors to determine the
long-term survival chip
mainly
and we hypothesize that the tumor micro
environment and the immune cell
infiltration
may be the key to determine the
long-term survival
in patient doctor
so based on this hypothesis our aim
and the aim of what i'm presenting today
is to reveal the immune and the
microenvironmental pathway
that may determine long-term survival in
energetic cancer patients
to achieve our aim we went back to the
archive we have
more than 20 we collected a big archive
more than 25 years
and we went to all these patients
material and their clinical information
you know the clinical
evaluation and treatment and we selected
the maximum number of survivals so we
have
10 patients who survive for five years
or longer
and we compare that to 10 patients who
survived
for six months or shorter and that was
our definition for long actual
third term survival and the first thing
we did
is we immediately profiled them
use using an encounter facility
nanotechnology string technology and
afterwards we selected subgroup of them
to be studied in the geomets dsp and
i'll come to back
i'll come to that in details later
our workflow we selected in this case in
the first
part of the study we selected fresh
frozen material we enrich
for tumor tissue so we section the
tissue samples and pathologists and
experienced pathologists would study
them
and then we enrich for tumor tissue
meaning we enrich our tumor cell
including dysmography or stroma that's
part of the tumor that needed rna
isolation
we checked the quality and we used 200
nanograms per reaction which includes 5
microliters of rna
good quality rna but fresh frozen
material usually gives good quality rna
and then we use the new profile panel
from nanostring we hybridized for 17
hours
we scanned 490 kilos of fuel
and we used the in solver advanced
analysis would you
to analyze ourselves and then we
validate it using the geometrics dsp
now a technical detail i'm not aware of
how familiar you are with an
technology and the principle of uh
of the world but just for a short notice
we used
a pancas the band cancer in your profile
panel
including 770 genes representing the
innate and the adaptive immune system
40 housekeeping genes there are 24
different cell
types and several pathways
and the advantage of using their panels
from
from nanostring is you hybridize rna
immediately with two drops so you
capture you capture
100 base pair of the rna immediately
without enzymes
using two props
50 base pair each and each prompt
at the end has a flag or a reporter prop
of several six fluorescent dyes to
present
various genes so it will give
account of the genes of your interest
is a volcano plot of the differential
expressions
so in this side and the right side there
are the genes that they are
overexpressed
or upregulated in the long term
survivals
and here are the in green and the green
direction
there are the genes that they are
overexpressed in the short-term
survivals
please notice that the y-axis represents
the look
10 p-value and the x-axis
represents the look two voltage change
so one here
is two in linear
so we have more than 14
differentially expressed chains at a
p-value of 0.01
and the fold of a change of 1.5
in both directions if we take these 1414
genes
in order to distinguish between the two
groups remember we have 10
patients per group then there is a good
separation
we did principal component analysis and
in gray you see long-term survivals
that they are separated from the
short-term survivals
of course they overlap a little bit but
the overlapping is not that big
so we are very happy with these results
then you can take the normalized
data and you can do you can create
heat maps or you can study for example
i'm very much interested in the most
differentially expression between the
both groups but you are allowed to do
all of that it's based on your taste
what i'm also very interested in is
knowing the differentially expressed
immune sometimes so how can we utilize
gene expression results by giving
cell markers to identify immune cells
i'm giving an example of a diesel
of the definition of b cells we use four
different
markers then we calculate the
correlation coefficient
between these four markers and for us
we define them based on or we trust
cell markers that they have a
correlation coefficient
higher than point sex
meaning like these cell markers behave
in the same way across all the symbols
and then you can trust them
to give you a score for yourselves
now if we look at the infiltrative cells
defined by cd45 they are not different
between long and short silver but if we
look at the basal score
then it's at significant different score
which represent a higher score a score
in long-term survivals as compared to
short
again the definition of the b cells in
this case
were represented by four markers this is
cd20
cr2 cd22 and cd19
and this attracts our attention because
actually the role
of b cells in pancreatic cancer remains
controversial it is suggested until now
that it is a new it has a rule of the
new submission
there are three publications were
published in 2016.
they suggest or they indicate that b
cells fuel pancreatic cancer pancreatic
adductor adrenocarcinoma
and they promote pancreatic tumor genes
however a more recent publication in
2019
such as the opposite please remember
that
these applications are limited with the
number of patients they use or say
samples of patients they use they also
are limited by the technique
most of these publications are based on
universal chemistry
and a lot of them are based on using
animal models we know that animal models
they don't represent
especially when we talk about immune
cells or immune system
they don't represent the situation
but we have a we have opposite
information in the literature
our results shows that measles
infiltrate more in the long term
survival
as compared to the short-term survivors
and that raises a lot of the questions
i'm going to address two of them today
one of the question is the location
where do they infiltrate
we talked that we i introduced the tumor
as a heterogeneous tumor so i'd like to
know
where exactly they infiltrate and what
are the other types of cells that they
interact with
and to answer these questions nanostring
has developed the geomets digital
spatial profile
a profiler platform in my opinion
it is a fantastic platform to answer our
questions
so now we take tissue sample and we
stain the tissue sample
with morphological markers so we
distinguish
between tumor cells in this case they
are
how we distinguish them with
transatlantic
marker in yellow and we distinguish
alpha smooth muscle acting in green
and any tumor cells which are positive
for cd45
they are ignorant and what we did
previously using the encounter platform
is
one sample we took a section we isolated
one
rna sample and then we did one
measurement
but now with the dsp one sample
can be as many as we want we are
focusing
fan side to keratin cd45
and alpha smoothness effect in other
words
using this technology you are able to
connect
biology to morphology
or expression how does it work
dancing developed a neural oncology
module in which it includes the core
module
to distinguish the most common types of
immune cells
as you can see city 20 cd3 cd4
ct45 and so on and so forth
and then they are coupled with other
modules based on your requestion
like drug in your oncology drug
targeting tubes
or activation status suppressive status
if status and across all types of
tumor cells these are antibodies these
antibodies
are conjugated with oligo that
oligo is odd uv clearable
so in practice what we do is we take a
section
a tissue section of four or five
micrometer paraffin embedded section
and we stain that suction section with
our morphological markers
fancy to keratin adjustment muscle actin
and cd4
and then we hybridize this section
after thermal morphological markers with
the cocktail of these antibodies
leave it overnight and
next day we are able to distinguish
based on the segments
we are able to profile
each one of our segments
severity and here is a real example this
is one
of the samples that we measure and
each one of these boxes these are 12
boxes rois
or asian of interest in each one of
these regions
of interest you see a circle and that
represents
for example circle number seven is
full of the green color green is an
accent
please remember please notice that it is
high area number seven is high in
atherosclerosis actin
it is very low in bad cytokeratin
and it is very low in cd45
and now we provide
i'll go to my target this is an example
of a long-term survival symbol
in which i chose this area this area
is filled with tumors sorry with immune
cells
and when we look at the profile of this
area
they were very high in cd20 which is a
marker
for b cells i forgot to tell you that
the
data can be normalized in different ways
what i'm presenting here the data were
normalized using positive controls and
housekeeping sheets
so area number eight in a long term
survival symbol
was filled with or had a high
expression counts of cd20
and here is another example of a short
term survival
in which i chose exactly the same
morphological area
this area is filled with immune cells it
is low in alpha smooth muscle acting and
it is low in fat cytokeratin
this is area number 10 and if we look
at the expression or the counts this
area is filled also
with 20 with cd20 which is a marker of
these
if we put these data together and we
notice
the value of the y-axis which is the
count
these two areas which is filled with
immune cells
are built with b-cells as well but in a
complete different range
long-term survival showed the range of 5
000 counts
and short sears short term survival
showed
at a count of 600
now this is one sample versus one sample
if you take six versus 6
and you put all the information together
the long term survivals
are much higher in infiltration with b
cells as compared to short term
survivals
and i'm here presenting areas that they
will fill within yourself
i'm not presenting fan psychology
in order to show it to you in a
different way
these are the areas of
alpha smooth muscle active so the
dysmoplasia and venkeretic cancer
in which um
the area in the right are overexpressed
in short
and the genes or the markers in them
these are genes these are proteins
in the left are overexpressed in long
and please
notice with me that cd20
is overexpressed with a good b value
and a very high fold of a change
twice as much in long-term survival as
short-term
and they are in a close approximately
with
t cells c4 cd11
c and cd68 which is macrophages
and monocytes
if we take the areas of pancytokitten
which represent the tumor
cells then we don't reach significant
results
in the long term survival we see the
same trend
but it is not significant however we see
a lot of significance
in box b3 cd regulatory cells
and immune suppressive cells in the
tumor cells themselves
so putting this information together
we saw that b cells infiltrated
in the stroma of long-term survival
and they are in close distance with cd4
cd8 c68 cd14
and cd11c cells
b cells had gained a lot of interest
at the beginning of 2020 in february
2020
three publications came in nature
almost in the same way and all of them
were referring to the important role
of b-cells in the long-term survivor or
in the good prognosis
of various types of cancer like melanoma
sarcoma and others but we are the first
to show this role in pancreatic cancer
so i'm now in the conclusions and i'd
like to conclude with you
to remind you that the immune
infiltration is one of the keys
that determine the survival and
pancreatic doctor latino carcinoma
they are infiltrated more in
long-term survivals meaning patients who
survived five years and longer
as compared to patients who survive six
months
and shorter and b
cells infiltration is associated with t
cells into cells and these dc's
dendritic cells
the high infiltration of t regulatory
cells was
mentored or monitored in the small
plastic tissue in the ductal
tumor cells of fractal tumor tissue or
pancreatic drug
we have a lot of more questions and we
actually have
clinical data to answer our questions
like to connect
then infiltration with the clinical
parameters we have or to study the band
cytokeratin or the tumor cells a little
bit more in details
to know what types of cells infiltrate
in the short-term survival in that case
but with that i would like to conclude
my presentation
and i hope i convince you that vessels
play an important role in
[Applause]
determining the survival shape of
pancreatic
octal carcinoma i'd like to thank people
who participate in the study
from the tip lab or the tumor in
pathology lab at erasmus medical center
and that lab is headed by professor egg
i'd also like to thank the
bioinformatics team
from nanstring that helped me to analyze
the data generated by
dsp and i very much appreciate the
involvement of the patients
the donation of the tissue that enabled
us to
to study the tissue and i'd like to
thank support kaspar for the financial
support and i would be very happy to
answer
your questions
thank you very much dr mustapha for the
nice talk
i have few questions for you too
can you please expand on how one can
identify
immune cell subside using gene
expression
of genes and actually i received this
question quite a lot
i'd like to go back to my slides and i
showed you the example of t-cells at
identification of pieces
so we use different um gene markers to
identify
an immune cell type and actually for
pancreatic cancer we
there is a publication in preparation
right now we use the cancer genome atlas
data
and we can calculate all the definition
of cells
by calculating the correlation
coefficient between the genes
so using public data
which is from the cancer you know the
cancer you know
atlas we calculated the correlation
coefficient
between the different types of
cell markers and we kept we trusted
those that they have 0.6
and higher to define the types of cells
in that way we are able to identify
various types of cells in a very
confident way
so the default of nanostring or in
solver advanced analysis the default
gives
various types of cells but we were able
to increase that
for example nanostring gives the b cells
we were able to increase it to plasma b
cells
regulatory b cells and memory b cells
in our dataset
we also do the same for t cells you do
the same for dendritic cells for any
type of cells you
distinguish or from the literature you
know the markers
the gene markers to identify types of
cells and then
check the correlation coefficient in
between the genes in order to determine
if you trust them in your data set or
not
that's how you define
immune cells using gene expressions
there are other softwares that they do
that one of the famous one
is a cell sword or a super sword
so it's a very well known technique
thank you since in your study you have
used both the bulk technology platform
as well as the tissue imaging platform
which kind of advice will you give
to researcher about which one to use
when the goal of your research is to
discover difference between two group of
interests
two groups um it is
based on your personal taste and the
time
money and effort number of samples that
you have in the study
the scientists want to do i think or the
scientists want to perform
um the way i chose
is to profile the samples using
encounter and then validating using
in geomex national spatial profile
the reason for that is because i think
it's a little bit
faster and cost effective if you do it
this way
you will study more samples
with the encounter and then you can
validate your results using
a smaller cohort of patients or of
samples
however you can do the same
you can do also the discovery and the
validation using
geomix dsp it depends on the symbols
from the number of symbols included in
the study
the dsp will make will allow you to
study the
symbols in much more details as
compared to the income
the encounter is usually i refer to it
as a suit
so you isolate rna and from the whole
sample
and then you measure the expression of
cells or the
you measure the expression of genes not
knowing
what gave rises to these expressions
in the dsp now you know exactly where
you are located in the tumor you study
their population that you want to study
it and you can do that at two levels
you can do that at the protein level
using antibodies quantitative conjugated
to oligos
or you can do that also at the rna level
which i think is a fantastic method to
study secreted cytokines
i hope
thank you what is the function of b
cells
in pancreatic cancer
very good question um
we our data show that it is
they are higher in patients who survive
longer
as compared to patients who survive
shorter it's a relative expression
so i'm assuming that there or i
am confident that that b cells in
pancreatic cancer they play
a good role they actually suppress the
tumor
however we still need to validate or not
validate to discover the factors
that facilitate b cells to infiltrate to
the tumor cells
to that human areas in long term
survivals
and the function of b cells is still
not known in pancreatic cancer we are
working on it
we are studying samples in much more
details
um but i cannot really give a precise
answer for that
question
thank you very much dr mustapha for the
presentation and the discussion
so at the end of this presentation i
hope i convince you that
um b cells play an important role in the
long term survival shift in
pancreatic active carcinoma but i hope i
bring a little bit
bigger message which is the important of
studying the tumor micro environment
again i'm concentrating here in
pancreatic cancer but we study
more tumors tumor microenvironment
is gaining a lot of attention lately
and the reason for that is because it is
it may open new therapeutic options
for patients who suffer from this bad
disease
so um i think
the effort the international effort that
we all put together
in understanding the human micro
environment whether it's pancreatic
cancer or
other types of cancers is
it will be great to put all this effort
together and to collaborate to connect
our databases
so to identify uh or to
discover more about the tumor
microenvironment
the more we are we understand the tumor
in general
the more we are going to be successful
in winning the battle against it
with that i'd like to conclude and once
again i'd like to thank
um that you are in the pathology lab at
erasmus medical center
um and i'd like to tell you that we have
the geomix dsp we
installed it just before corona era
and i cannot wait to start working with
it
i also would like to thank lannistering
for hosting and for arranged
organizing this virtual conference
and if you have any question i have i'd
be happy to answer them at any time